hey guys how's it going welcome to
cooking with Justine I'm really excited
because I am here to actually not cook
anything today but I want to tell you
guys about a really fun series that I
want to do what's called Italy have a
name but it's all featured around summer
snacks so I recently had three million
YouTube subscribers here this summer so
I want to celebrate by making some
summer treats for you guys so I plan is
to make a summer treat for an entire
week so every day but we have fun little
treat that I make slide a few ideas
things that I want to make but I wanted
to get some ideas from you guys because
most of the fun things that I end up
making here are really cool ideas that
you guys either leave me in the YouTube
comments or that you send me on Twitter
but that being said leave me some
comments of some things that you would
like me to make whether it's a fun
recipe that your family likes to make
during the summer or it's something that
you just found on the internet you can
also tweet me add I just een hashtag a
Justine cooking and if you guys send
photos on Twitter I usually see those
much easier but make sure you do link to
the recipe so I can actually see how to
make it because if this is not the first
time you're watching and I just mean
cooking video then you know I definitely
need the directions and even if I have
the directions I probably won't really
follow them anyway but at least I try
thank you guys so much for watching and
thank you so much to all three million
YouTube subscribers I can't believe that
I've been on YouTube for so long and
it's still it's something that is just
so much fun and I love you guys and I
hope to see you sometime soon might be
the grocery store well picking up all
these groceries well it's summer snacks
I said some snacks of you later I'll
look forward to your ideas and
suggestions peace